President Trump and your staffing
problems announces tariffs and tanks the
markets and says we should give drug
dealers the death penalty so things are
going awesome Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show
it's been a rough 48 hours for the
President of the United States it has
not been solid and we will go through
all of the non solidity in just a second
there are some real staffing issues over
at the White House and chaos in terms of
the internal dynamics at the White House
plus the presidents of the United States
Unleashed the most ignorant tweed storm
I have ever seen from him and that is
saying a lot here this one was on trade
policy and it is just freakin a grease
set mean really I met my four-year-old
daughter can probably do a better
explanation of trade and if it sounds
like I'm being too harsh I'm being not
harsh enough it's that bad so I will
explain all of that again guys don't
take it as though Trump's never done
anything good he's done lots of good
stuff but his trick up I'll get to it
okay so before I get to any of that
first let's say thank you to our
sponsors over at Birch gold so right now
you may have noticed the stock market is
quite volatile it just got more volatile
because the president said a bunch of
stupid crap on trade so now would be a
good time for you to take some of that
money he got in the stock market and
maybe invested in some precious metals
that aren't going to be touched by the
stupidity of American trade policy and
or inflationary policy so check it out
over at Birch gold group they've a
long-standing track record of continued
success with thousands of satisfied
clients countless five-star reviews a
plus rating with the Better Business
Bureau
if you contact him right now you get a
free information kit on physical
precious metals this comprehensive 16
page kit shows how gold and silver can
protect your savings as well as how you
can legally move your IRA or 401k out of
stocks and bonds and into a precious
metals IRA to get that no-cost
no-obligation kit again go to
birchgold.com slash pen that is
birchgold.com slash been suffice it to
say that as of January 28 the stock
market was twenty six thousand four
hundred today is it at twenty four
thousand three hundred can it's a two
thousand point drop in about five weeks
not wonderful so now would be a good
time for you to take a look at what led
maybe investing in some gold to go to
birchgold.com slash Bennie's that slash
Ben C at the free comprehensive kit and
so that you also let them know that we
sent you okay so as I mentioned the
markets not having a couple of good days
they're down five straight days and
they've dropped in the last five days
approximately a thousand points now is
that the end of the world no it's not
the end of the world except they dropped
a thousand points the month before so
one of the reasons they continued to
drop is because the President of the
United States does not know what the
hell he is talking about on trade and I
say this advice
okay the president I don't know if he
got his degree in from Wharton Business
School on trade from turning in
crackerjack box tops honestly I don't
know if he got like a decoder ring in
the mail I don't know where he learned
his economics but it is awful it is just
awful and he's actually implementing it
so as I said yesterday he said a bunch
of stupid crap on guns and then he's not
gonna implement any of it because
Congress is going to stop him on trade
the president has plenary power
essentially on trade because Congress
has abdicated its duty over the past 50
years and given the president the
ability to raise and lower tariffs
essentially on his own for virtually any
purpose here is what Trump tweeted out
today it's really really dumb okay this
is six hours ago when a country USA
Thank You mr. president is losing many
billions of dollars on trade with
virtually every country it does business
with trade wars are good and easy to win
example when we are down 100 billion
with a certain country and they get cute
don't trade anymore we win big it's easy
the levels of stupidity are like a
Russian nesting doll here you open up
the top level of stupidity and there's
another level of stupidity beneath it
except it's an infinite regress of
nesting dolls because there is no
tiniest nesting doll of stupidity in
this tweet okay so we'll go through this
sentence by sentence when he says that
we are losing many billions of dollars
on trade you don't lose money on trade
when you go to amazon.com and you buy
yourself a used book did you lose money
on the trade no you voluntarily opted to
buy a product when you go to a grocery
store and they give you an apple and you
give them 50 cents did you lose money on
the trade no you bought an apple for 50
cents this is the necessity of how trade
works it is a two sided exchange a
voluntary consensual exchange
demonstrating both that you have
consented to the exchange and that you
have free will over your own labor and
can trade your own labor and the
products of it for something else this
is the magic of free trade it's not just
a free trade is more efficient though it
is it's also that it is more moral
because you get to determine how much
your labor is worth and how much your
money is worth and if you don't like
paying 50 cents for an Apple here you
can go down the street and you can pay
40 cents for an Apple somewhere else
because of competition in free trade
when he says that trade deficits are
necessitate trade wars and we says trade
wars are good and easy to win name one
name a
trade war that was good and easy to win
you can't win a trade war let me take my
example a little bit further so you went
to the grocery store and you bought a
hundred dollars worth of groceries but
the grocery store does not contract with
you the grocery store doesn't buy
anything from you the grocery store
doesn't use your services because after
all you're a garbage man and the grocery
store doesn't need you so do well how do
you retaliate against the grocery store
are you angry at the grocery store
because they didn't use your services
and do you decide that what the best
possible solution would be is to not go
to Ralph's but instead to go to Gelson's
where everything is twice as much and go
over to Gelson's and pay twice the
amount because raus isn't using you and
Gelson's might is this what you're going
to do or forget about whether Gelson's
is using you right Gelson's may not use
you either but you decide that you're
gonna penalize Ralph's because Ralph's
used to use you and now they're no
longer using you so you decide to pay
twice as much for your groceries does
this make any sense if amazon.com is not
hiring you as a contractor do you stop
shopping at Amazon and instead go over
to the local bookstore and pay twice as
much money
of course you don't because that would
be stupid your trade deficit with Amazon
is whatever it is that you paid for the
product when you buy from the grocery
store you now have a trade deficit of
$100 if you spend $100 on your groceries
because the grocery store didn't buy
anything from you does that mean you
should go to a more expensive grocery
store and then if you boycott the
grocery store you have somehow won no it
means that you just chopped your own leg
off because you're stupid
okay that's what trade wars are this has
been known since the days of Ricardo
David Ricardo has been known for 300
years this is 16th century mercantilism
he's talking about here and it's a giant
fail when he says when we're down a
hundred billion dollars with a certain
country and they get cute don't trade
anymore we win big ok there are many
countries in the world that have trade
surpluses overall trade surpluses let me
name one of those countries that has a
trade surplus for you Venezuela
Venezuela has a trade surplus you know
why because no one because they're there
because no one in Venezuela has the
ability to buy anything for it they put
up enormous tariffs and so Venezuela has
a trade surplus and people are eating
dogs people are literally eating dogs in
the street trade surplus trade deficit
mean nothing because all a trade surplus
or trade deficit recognizes is that you
are paying another country for product
you're voluntarily participating in
exchange and then that money is not
being paid back by that country
to you but here's the magic of trade
also when you pay a dollar for a Chinese
product and it ends up in China what do
you think happens to that dollar do you
think they just take it and store it
somewhere do you think that it magically
turns into yen so now they've won so
they can now turn around and use it in
China no they have to use it in the
United States because we have a
different currency than they do so they
turn around and they invest it back in
the United States in our stock market in
our bonds this is how the economic on
imme works you have to be so
economically ignorant to tweet something
like this it is truly amazing
but Trump didn't stop there here's some
other stuff that he tweet we quote we
must protect our country and our workers
our steel industry is in bad shape if
you don't have steel you don't have a
country what now
again this is very stupid we don't put
our steel industry is not in bad shape
our steel industry as I told you
yesterday was up 5% in production last
year and all of our steel companies have
had stock increases over the last 10 to
15 years
Nucor which is the top tool steel
producer in the United States it's stock
prices at $12 in 2000 it is now at $65
they're telling me that the steel
industry is dying in the United States
is doing just fine
seventy two point five percent of all
steel consumed in the United States is
also produced in the United States our
steel industry is not dying also
somebody should inform Switzerland if
they're not a country anymore because
Switzerland does not produce its own
steel in fact many countries don't
produce their own steel they don't
produce it on steel because sometimes
they don't have the actual materials
available to produce their own steel
does this mean the country doesn't exist
anymore I'm not aware that Israel
produces lots of its own steel I don't
think Israel has like great steel
deposits or deposits and they import
most of their steel is Israel not a
country anymore and not a powerful
country anymore of course not because
that's stupid and then he says he
explains further professor professor
Trump he explains when a country taxes
our products coming in and say 50% and
we taxed the same products coming into
our country at 0% not fair or smart we
will soon be starting reciprocal taxes
so we will charge the same thing as they
charge us 800 billion dollar trade
deficit have no choice again this is
dumb let's say the China taxes our
products 50% coming in right they tax
every product that we send them 50%
coming in which means presumably we're
not selling as many products they're you
know what else is happening Chinese
citizens are paying at least 50%
more for the same product there
impoverishing their own citizens they're
just making their own citizens pay more
for a products they could have gotten
more cheaply elsewhere so is the
solution for the united states to jack
up its own prices remember everyone in
the united states is both a producer and
a consumer in the steel industry there
gonna be a lot of people who are very
happy with the tariffs because now they
don't have to compete with foreign
sources but for every steel job there
are 45 jobs in this country that use
steel inputs whose prices just went up
so Wilbur Ross the the Commerce
Secretary whose most famous for falling
asleep in cabinet meetings and drooling
I'm serious okay real is not a joke okay
that was reported by the New York Times
apparently Trump got pissed at it
because he would legitimately fall
asleep in cabinet meetings top men okay
and Wilbur Ross goes on television today
and he says you know there's a ton of
Steel and American cars and that means
that if you raise the tariffs by 25%
it's only raising the amount of the car
by like half of 1% chump change
number one not necessarily chump change
to the guy who's paying for the car next
100 75 bucks on the $35,000 car is not
necessarily chump change to everybody
hey that's number one number two you're
assuming that you can just make the
calculation by the amount of steel in a
car that's not correct there are lots of
contractors between the or and between
the car okay in every step of the way
there is markup so if there is a steel
product that is used in the making of an
engine that is very often outsourced to
another company that means the DAP
company now has to pay more for the
steel which means that they manufacture
the product and they don't just pass the
amount of the cost on they pass the
amount plus the labor plus the profit
right that means now they're charging
more for that input and let's say it's a
piece of an engine now somebody has to
put that engine together and so they
have to buy that product which is
already marked up so they mark it up
even more and this is how tariffs
snowball when the President of the
United States Barack Obama raised
tariffs on Chinese tires
we lost 12,000 jobs in the in the auto
industry because Barack Obama raised the
prices of tires okay and tires are a lot
cheaper to manufacture and make and sell
than cars are hey this is all stupid it
doesn't make any sense it's economically
illiterate and it's so funny there are
all these people today or oh oh oh this
is what from Brunt on they ran on this
so obviously he's gonna do it yeah I
didn't hear you saying the same thing
about Barack Obama he ran a lot of
garbage too and then he did a lot of
that garbage we were all kind of pissed
about it I recall yeah I was angry
when Trump said this stuff during the
campaign this is not me new to the game
here hey I was reading full pieces in
March 2016 about why Trump's trade
policy was idiotic he and Bernie Sanders
basically have the same trade policy
note to everyone if you have the same
policy on anything as Bernie Sanders
you're stupid hey you should not have
the same policy as Bernie Sanders on
things Bernie Sanders policy is awful
awful awful so in just a second I'm
gonna explain to you all of the reasons
why tariffs are bad we can go back to
economic rudiments we're gonna go back
to the very beginning and I'll speak in
short words and phrases so that people
can understand because it seems like
there are a lot of people don't
understand if it seems like I'm angry
about this it's because I am this is
legitimately econ 101 hey this is not
complex it is not difficult it really is
not hey just take it down to your normal
everyday interaction with other people
and you see how dumb this argument is
the other reason I'm angry is if you
want the president to have a successful
term then you would like for the economy
to be good there are a lot of people
saying hey well don't worry about
everything he says don't worry the 57%
of the American public by polls think
the president's a racist if the economy
is good everything will be fine and the
president says hold my beer I'm starting
a trade war okay great it's great it
alright well we'll explain all of this a
little bit more in just a second first I
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at my Patriot supply so right now
there's natural disasters going on all
around the world in Puerto Rico they're
still trying to recover from natural
disasters imagine there's a natural
disaster in your area and the government
can't get to you and all the grocery
store shelves have been emptied because
the chain of supply has been disrupted
by a stupid trade war and imagine that
you now have to figure out how to live
well the best way to do that is going to
be with a is going to be by talking my
friends over at my Patriot supply okay
right now as I say in Puerto Rico there
are people going with food with fort
without food for weeks after disaster
and then finally a FEMA truck will roll
through through the neighborhood and
drop off a care package and inside it's
mostly junk food well you don't need to
be the person who stuck like that this
week get my Patriot supplies one-year
emergency food supply for just 999
dollars okay you heard that right this
is one year's worth of food for under a
thousand bucks and normally you know
you're talking about getting like enough
for just a little while but again in
Puerto Rico it is months past natural
disaster month past natural disaster and
people still don't have the food
they need this kit normally sells for
over two thousand dollars but this week
for 999 dollars you get a one-year
emergency food supply call eight eight
eight eight oh three fourteen thirteen
and ask for the Ben Shapiro one-year
food kit special price nine hundred
ninety nine dollars when you use my name
you get that special price otherwise
gonna be paying a couple grand for it or
order online at prepare with Ben calm no
more relying on a few minutes India an
old bag of potato chips it's gonna last
you for a day it's time your family was
self-reliant 888 803 1413 888 803 1413
or prepare with Ben calm again that's
prepare with Ben calm no reason for you
to be reliant on the government under
any circumstances and this is a one-time
buy because this food last 25 years in
storage so you do it once you never
gonna have to worry about it again
888 803 1413 8 8 8 803 1413 or prepare
with Ben calm again prepare with Ben
calm let them know that we sent you ok
so as I say the Presidents tariff policy
is full-on ridiculous
ok it is not good and here is why it's
just number one tariffs are an unfair
tax you are taxing one industry on
behalf of another industry you are
taxing people who buy cars on behalf of
the steel industry and jobs will be lost
in the car industry because you are
attempting to save jobs in the steel
industry as I said yesterday there are
two hundred thousand jobs that were lost
in the United States between 2001 and
2003 because of george w bush's far less
stringent steel tariffs and Trump isn't
just talking steel tariffs anymore he's
talking about full scale trade war with
everybody who has tariffs on our
products which is just brilliant if all
of these countries which wish to charge
their own citizens more for products to
protect their domestic industries then
fine we should take advantage of that
you get richer when you buy cheaper
products if you don't have to pay as
much for stuff you're getting richer and
we're not all reliant on foreign tricky
the United States a massive market
economy we generate most of what we
produce I mean we do most of what we
produce we consume here in the United
States I'm in most businesses so if
everybody else decides that they are
going to try to try to destroy our
ability to import into their country to
export into their country then why
exactly would we cut off our nose to
spite our face by making our own
consumers pay more just to make any more
sense as I say tariffs also destroy jobs
when you remove money from profitable
industries people who don't need tariffs
and subsidies to survive and you give it
to those who are inefficient it keeps
jobs in industries that are less
efficient and if companies
is never loud then products quality
actually declines over time so you're
buying worst cars over time if you tear
up foreign cars and then when you open
up the market because people are tired
of buying crappy American cars for
example it's what happened in the 1970s
then it's we're flooded with a bunch of
Japanese cars and suddenly the American
market share goes down dramatically this
is exactly what happened in the 1960's
and 1970's in the American auto industry
tariffs actually create zombie
industries okay America is not as I say
damaged by unfair trade practices of
other countries in the sense that they
put a tariff on us and therefore we are
greatly hurt currencies an exchange unit
so all of the talk about how China also
is is manipulating its currency okay if
manipulating currency were that easy and
that profitable if that were really the
big issue in America then we would just
print a bunch of money and we walk
around with wheelbarrows like why Marge
Herman II and the people in vitam our
journey or in Venezuela today or in
Zimbabwe where inflation was at one
point at 1,000 percent a day those
people were not immensely wealthy they
were immensely poor inflation inflating
your currency is a sign that you don't
have a strong underlying fundamental
economy trade is not a zero-sum game
hey this is from Thomas solo in general
international deficits and surpluses
have had virtually no correlation with
the performance of most nations
economies Germany and France have had
international trade surpluses while
their unemployment rates were in double
digits Japan's post-war rise to economic
prominence on the world stage included
years when it ran deficits and years
when it ran surpluses the United States
was the biggest debtor nation in the
world during its rise to industrial
supremacy became a creditor as a result
of lending money to its European allies
during the First World War and has been
both the debtor and a creditor at
various times since through it all the
American standard of living has remained
the highest in the world unaffected by
whether it was a creditor or a debtor
nation Thomas solo points out that if
Japanese sold us a lot of cars when we
send them lots of dollar they're gonna
use those dollars to buy American assets
Scott Lincecum who is a trade lawyer at
Cato he says every dollar traveling
overseas to buy imports in excess of our
exports eventually comes back to the
u.s. in the form of investment our trade
deficit is matched by a capital account
surplus in other words we buy goods and
services from foreigners they buy an
equal amount of our exports plus our
financial assets
aka foreign investment in the United
States and here's the here's the key
okay if trade we're really about just
beating the other guy to prevent them
from importing stuff why not just sync
all the Chinese ships bringing products
into the country does anyone
that'd be good for the economy no
because this is stupid s T wo PID stupid
okay so in a second we're gonna move on
from Trump steel tariffs apparently
virtually every country in the world is
now threatening countermeasures for
steep new tariffs and remember how
President Trump put on a bunch of
tariffs on a Canadian lumber we now a
shortage of Canadian we now a shortage
of lumber in the United States that's
been working out fantastically well for
people in the United States okay we're
gonna get to other things that are
happening in the White House again it's
been a rough 48 hours for the White
House it's not a pylon it's just the
truth we're gonna get to that in just
one second okay so here is the here is
the latest on the chaos inside the White
House so right now here is where things
stand Howe picks the president's top
aide is stepping down Jared Kushner one
of the people the president is closest
to just lost his top-level security
clearance Gary Cohn who has discussed
his chief of staff replace John Kelly
about a week and a half ago and is the
head of Trump's economic program is now
threatening to quit a national security
adviser HR McMaster
is apparently on the ropes as well so
basically every top-level administrator
except for John Kelly is on the ropes
that is not the sign of a healthy
administration even John Kelly doesn't
sound super enthused about all of this
here's the White House chief of staff
yesterday talking about taking the job
as White House White House chief of
staff and moving on from Homeland
Security
truly at six months the last thing I
wanted to do is walk away from one of
the great honors of my life being the
Secretary of Homeland Security but I did
something wrong and God punished me I
guess
now there's an enthusiastic guy about
his new job of keeping the president
under control
i punished him by moving on to the White
House he talked about how he's happy to
be helping the president push the agenda
I'm sure he is but it is not an easy job
the reason to turn over at the White
House is so high is because everything
is variable over there now
let it be known this does not mean that
everything that Trump is doing is bad
okay the President of the United States
by the time he has finished his first
term will have replaced almost half of
all of the judges on circuit courts
across the country that's a wonderful
thing he's doing a great job on that
because he's delegated it out but when
Trump is bored and he gets his hands on
the gears of power when he when he grabs
those levers and he starts playing video
games all that comes out is bad stuff
okay the president needs to be
disciplined this is not because I want
him to lose it's because I would like
for him to be a good president and I
would like for the
country to win with him I like winning
and the president supposedly likes
winning - I'll tell you what is not
winning what is not winning is putting
forward gun proposals to seize weapons
from a huge variety of citizens what is
not winning is suggesting a massive
trade war across the board as I said
earlier the EU is now threatening
massive retaliatory tariffs on the
United States which is just wonderful
a great way to tank the economy you know
we've tried this before by the way and
the smoot-hawley Tariff in 1930 are
widely perceived to have led to the
Great Depression and helped exacerbate
it into a ten-year Great Depression as
opposed to a relatively insignificant
recession hey none of this makes any
sense
one of the reasons that Trump is doing
all this stuff now is because when Trump
is isolated when he feels like he
doesn't have all the people around him
he likes to have around him when hope
Hicks is gone and Jordan Ivanka have
been marginalized and it's just a bunch
of people he doesn't know like John
Kelly sitting around him he feels like
he has to go back to his gut and has got
uncertain issues is not bad and on other
issues it is surely terrible and on
trade it is surely terrible the New York
Times is reporting on the situation in
the White House apparently people in the
White House did not even know that Trump
was going to announce the steel tariffs
and aluminum tariffs yesterday by the
way the price of beer is going to go up
- every beer can in America is used is
made with aluminum which means that if
you like your beer you're not gonna get
to keep your beer the price on it is
gonna go up which is I think most
Americans are not going to be super
happy with that the previous day
according to the New York Times mr.
Trump's chief economic adviser Gary Cohn
more than the chief of staff John Kelly
he might resign if the president went
ahead with the plan according to people
briefed on the discussion Cohan had
lobbied fiercely against the measures
we'll see if he quits next week if Trump
actually implements this stuff as I said
the stock market today
has taken a dump yesterday it also took
a dump it's down about 200 points right
now that is better than it was earlier
this morning when it was down about 380
points so we will see usually it's
around three o'clock in the afternoon
they finally find out what exactly the
markets gonna do today but as I say the
five-day forecast on the market has been
pretty garbage the high was 25 thousand
seven hundred sixty-one today it is now
a two thousand two 24,400 so that means
that we've lost well over a thousand
points in the last five days on the Dow
Jones Industrial Average the reason we
haven't lost more than that is because
people don't know if Trump's actually
going to do what he says it's going to
do
people are pricing uncertainty into the
market well anyway White House aides
arrived at work on Thursday they had no
clear idea of what Trump would say about
trade
he'd summon steel in aluminum's to a
meeting when the White House said only
that he would listen to their concerns
it seemed to signal that Cohn had held
on but at the end of the photo session a
reporter asked Trump about the measures
and he confirmed that the US would
announce next week it is imposing
long-term tariffs of 25 percent on steel
and 10 percent on aluminum now how can
you tell this is not the effect of
trumps of massive expertise on trade
even his guy on trade and in Peter
Navarro is not good on trade Peter
Navarro had recommended a 24 percent
tariffs on steel
he went to trunks at 24% tariffs on
steel what did Trump do he said no 25
because it's in round number if we are
going to be setting tariffs based on
multiples of 5 let me suggest this is
not an outgrowth of economic expertise
it is rather an outgrowth of economic
foolishness well obviously there's been
tremendous turnover in the White House
and the discomfort that Trump is feeling
is obvious to everyone again when he
says things like the WTO has been a
disaster for this country and it's been
great for China and terrible for the
United States and great for other
countries why is it the United States
still has the most powerful economy in
world history and why is it that we
generate virtually all of the economic
growth on planet earth why is that a so
there's so there's that as well so all
of this is just wonderful and another
piece of bad news coming down for the
White House I'm sorry to give all this
bad news today another piece of bad news
coming down for the White House that I
will discuss in just one second first I
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at zip recruiter so every business
needs great people and a better way to
find them we at the Daily wire are
constantly hiring and firing and
hopefully everybody in this room it will
remain employed I can't guarantee it
guys I can't but if you are fired the
good news will you zip recruiter to
replace you so zip recruiter is the best
place to get great employees zip
recruiter learns what you're looking for
identifies people with the right
experience and invites them to apply to
your job in fact 80% of employee of
employers who post a job on zip
recruiter get a quality candidate
through the site in just one day and zip
recruiter does not stop there they even
spot like the strongest applications you
receive so you never miss a great match
the right candidates are out there zip
recruiter is how you can find them right
now my listeners get to try zip
recruiter for free so go to zip
recruiter comm slash daily wire at zip
recruiter com
slash daily wire and again when you zip
recruiters icon slash daily wire my
listeners can tricep recruiter for free
can post your jobs for free zip
recruiter comm slash daily wire it is
the smartest way to hire you are gonna
get the best employees through this
service again zip recruit calm slash
daily wire that also lets them know then
we sent you okay so another piece of
unfortunate is for the White House so
president Trump has been on a tear
against Andrew McCabe the ex deputy
director of the FBI and the reason that
he was been on a tear against Andrew
McCabe is because his supposition is
that McCabe and Co me and the rest of
the FBI were out to get him during the
last election cycle and in the
post-election period well now it turns
out that a Justice Department review is
actually expected to criticize Andrew
McCabe but at the former FBI deputy
director under Comey
it's expected to criticize McCabe why
because he was too mean to Hillary
Clinton
so just so Trump's own Justice
Department is about to find that Andrew
McCabe the guy that Trump has been
ripping on it wasn't that he was too
hard on Trump is that he was too hard on
Hillary Clinton hey they're gonna
condemn him for authorizing the
disclosure of information about a
continuing investigation to journalists
according to four people familiar with
the inquiry such a damning report would
give Trump at new ammunition to
criticize McCabe who's at the center of
Trump's theory the deep state actors
inside the FBI have been working to
sabotage his presidency but mr. McCabe's
disclosures to the news media do not fit
neatly into that assumption they
contributed to a negative article about
Hillary Clinton and the Obama
administration's DOJ not mr. Trump the
department's Inspector General Michael
Horowitz has zeroed in on disclosures to
the Wall Street Journal as part of a
wide-ranging investigation into among
other things how the FBI approached the
2016 inquiry into mrs. Clinton's
handling of classified information mr.
Horowitz said he expects to release a
report this month or next so McCabe
already said he was going to step down
he stepped down as deputy director in
late January so all of this is fodder
for Trump that the FBI is corrupt but
unfortunately the corruption doesn't
seem to run toward Trump it seems to run
toward they're a bunch of people in the
FBI who are deeply discomforted with
hillary clinton's corruption and we're
releasing information to the press which
cuts against Trump's argument okay that
is not good for Trump right Trump's
whole argument is the FBI is out to get
him
I've been skeptical of the story that
the FBI was out to get Trump
and I still think there are open
questions about how the FISA warrants
were used against Kyra Paige whether the
FISA courts in general take bad
information and turn them into warrants
but I've been unconvinced by the
evidence produced so far that the FBI
was out to target trombe out to destroy
Trump out to destroy his administration
I think they're bad people inside the
FBI like Peter struck and Lisa Paige
those people should have been fired and
Miller did fire them I think the FBI's
current investigation into Trump Russia
collusion is going to come up with
nothing I think that what the FBI doing
is doing right now is overblown
but I don't think that during the
transition period the evidence is there
yet maybe it'll be shown maybe well I
don't think the evidence is there yet
that the FBI was quote-unquote out to
get Trump as opposed to their
overzealous on virtually everything and
this is just another thing that they are
overzealous on okay so in other bad news
for Trump again it's been a bad Trump
day and I hope that by the time we get
to Monday he's turned it around and
things are going great again but okay
this is not a great indicator yesterday
the President did a hearing an open
forum on the opioid crisis and and it
was very moving Eric Bolling did a video
message about his son who died of an
opioid addiction died an opioid overdose
and Trump showed up and in the process
he said that we should execute drug
dealers in the United States and we have
drug dealers that don't mean they kill
hundreds and hundreds of people and most
of them don't even go to jail you know
if you shoot one person they gave you
life they give you the death penalty
these people can kill 2,000 3,000 people
and nothing happens to him and we need
strength with respect to the pushers and
to the drug dealers and if we don't do
that you're never gonna solve the
problem if you want to be weak and you
want to talk about just blue ribbon
committees that's not the answer the
answer is you have to have strength and
you have to have toughness the drug
dealers the drug pushers are they're
really doing damage they're really doing
damage some countries have a very very
tough penalty the ultimate penalty okay
when he when he says some countries have
the very toughest penalty the ultimate
penalty he's talking about the
Philippines where they legitimately
execute drug dealers so there are
already laws on the books that if you're
a drug kingpin and your drugs result in
death that you can't actually get the
death penalty in
United States but if we're going to
extend this to all drug dealers across
the country that if you're dealing pot
then we're not going to actually cute
you I think this might be a little bit
over the top so in the last 48 hours the
presidents in the United States has
suggested number one removing guns from
people without due process if they are
alleged to be mentally ill number two he
has started in trade war and number
three he has suggested that we execute
drug dealers so it's been a very solid
48 hours for the for the White House now
he walked back a lot of the gun stuff
yesterday so the president did walk back
some of the guns stuff yesterday he
tweeted out last night that he had met
with people over at the NRA the same NRA
that he was ripping his corrupt just two
days ago and even he I think Trump's
feeling some heat from his right which
is good you know one of my great fears
before Trump was elected was the
soul-sucking of the Republican Party the
soul-sucking of the conservative
movement that a lot of people were just
gonna follow Trump wherever he goes
because the president is the president
and he has a lot of public sway and I do
think that we've seen a couple of areas
where the where the conservative
commentariat is not willing to go even a
lot of Trump supporters so Tucker
Carlson is a good example of this so
Tucker yesterday I had this to say about
the president's talk his loose talk
about guns at one point the president
said the government should quote take
the guns first go through due process
second now I mean how honest do you want
to be imagine if Barack Obama had said
that just ignore due process and start
confiscating guns well bomb would have
been denounced as a dictator we would
have denounced him first trust me
Congress would be talking impeachment
right now someone be muttering about
secession well the media agreed with
what the president said yesterday so
they've under played it or they presents
it as just a little battle between the
president and the NRA
okay so there's Tucker Carlson ripping
into Trump pretty rare thing when you
see Tucker ripping into Trump but again
Trump's not had a good 48 hours good for
Tucker and good for conservatives who
are saying when things are wrong they're
wrong whether it's Trump saying it or
whether it's Obama is saying it okay so
we'll continue with this and also a poll
that shows that Democrats really do want
to grab guns I don't just mean some
Democrats I mean a majority of Democrats
it's an amazing pool I'm gonna tell you
about that in just second you're gonna
have to go over to Facebook for that so
you're gonna have to go over to to a
Daily wire for that and subscribe so
$9.99 a month gets you a subscription to
our
daily wire account that means that you
can see the rest of our show live it
means the rest of the Michel Noel's show
live it means the rest of the Andrew
Clavin shall I the means that today we
have the mailbag and we'll answer your
questions in the mailbag and you can ask
live questions in the mailbag and we
will answer them you just go to our chat
room and you type in questions we'll
answer them live on air you can do that
right now this very moment go subscribe
and that means we will answer your
questions on air okay and if you want
all of those things plus this the very
finest in beverage press let me says
it's a high-quality beverage vessel I
found out yesterday what this cost at
wholesale and let me tell you it ain't
cheap okay these things are awesome okay
this is the leftist here's hot or cold
tumbler and you get that with your
annual subscription for just $99 the
whole shebang and that means that you
get all of the aforementioned glories
and this which will grant you life and
wonder so check it out also you want to
listen later go over to iTunes
SoundCloud YouTube please subscribe
please leave a serve you it always helps
we're the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
so Democrats are jumping on board with
with what Trump was suggesting and this
is why I said yesterday I'm not super
worried about what Trump had to say
yesterday because right now Republicans
are in charge of the Congress
what happens if Democrats win control
the Congress well I have a good hint for
you as to what happens they listen to
what Trump says they go they talk with
Trump and then Trump says this sort of
stuff and they draw up legislation
specifically to the to his specs they
draw it up for him and they pass it
through the house and then it's up to
Mitch McConnell to stand between you and
doom and everybody who's ripping on
Mitch McConnell is the weakling who had
to be defeated by the trumpets then
Mitch McConnell was the guy who had to
be stood up too because he was too weak
in caving to the left if the Democrats
were in the house things are gonna get
real nasty and Mitch McConnell could be
the guy standing between conservatism
and disaster and we will see how that
goes
ok but here is what the Washington
Examiner reported this yesterday Senate
Democrats said they will introduce a gun
control bill that would expand
background checks ban certain weapons
and give the courts the power to
temporarily take guns away from people
who are deemed to be a threat to
themselves and others after President
Trump offered support for these goals in
a White House discussion on Wednesday
Senate Minority Leader Chuck Schumer
said the only way to advance the measure
in the GOP led Senate is with the
endorsement and help from President
Trump he described a scenario in which
the Senate could pass Schumer's proposal
with mostly Democratic support and a few
Republicans encouraged by Trump and
Schumer then reached out to Trump
directly and said that the president
should endorse the Schumer plan he said
the president is the first step
he said the McConnell would not bring up
the bill without the president's
persuasion so as I say Trump you have
the NRA in the room everything was
hunky-dory but House Democrats Senate
Democrats they put together basically a
gun ban bill and they're asking Trump to
take the lead on it if they were to take
control of the house in the Senate you
can't rely on their good graces to
maintain gun rights hey here is a poll
they pulled from YouGov it asked people
whether they favor or oppose banning
semi-automatic weapons not
semi-automatic rifles all semi-automatic
weapons that means all semi-automatic
pistols semi-automatic handguns
semi-automatic rifles here are the poll
numbers are you ready for this okay 55
percent of Americans say they support
they favor strongly or favor somewhat
banning all semi-automatic weapons in
the United States okay that is the
removal of 300 million guns from people
in the United States okay and by party
ID 82% of Democrats 82% of Democrats are
in favor of removing all semi-automatic
weapons from the citizens of the United
States banning them okay that is the
question the question was banning them
okay now here's where it gets totally
crazy okay then
they followed up by asking people how
they feel about banning all handguns
which would include revolvers so now
we're not talking just semi-automatic
weapons we were talking all semi autos
and all revolvers the difference in
revolver and a semi-automatic weapon is
that when you shoot a revolver then the
cylinder moves and it read chambers by
moving the cylinder and when you shoot a
semi-automatic handgun one bullet pops
up into the chamber automatically every
time you fail every time you fire a
bullet until the the magazine is empty
okay here are the numbers on people who
would ban all guns all of them okay you
ready so favors strongly favor somewhat
only 26% of Americans favor strongly or
favor somewhat banning all of all guns
banning all handguns hey among Democrats
among Democrats ready for this forty
let's see this is 44 percent of
Democrats forty-four percent of
Democrats say they favor it forty forty
six percent of Democrats say they do not
okay so that means that they are
basically split 50/50 on repealing the
Second Amendment by taking away all guns
in the United States they're split 50-50
on whether to remove all guns in the
United States in other words they are
exactly what you thought they were
hey Democrats are people who want to
remove as many guns as possible in the
United States and then they have the
gall to tell people like us but they
don't actually want to remove the Second
Amendment from folks no they're all
good-hearted no they don't want to take
away your done they want to take away
your gun it's obvious they want to take
away your gun and this is why it matters
when the president of the United States
endorses their program and why it is
imperative that Republicans keep the
house and keep the Senate in next year's
election cycle now there are a couple of
obstacles to keeping the house the
latest polls are one obstacle the second
obstacle is if the economy doesn't
particularly do well then that's going
to hurt them and the third obstacle is a
lot of the gerrymandering a lot of the
redistricting that's happened over the
past several years actually has not been
particularly good as good for
Republicans as they thought that it was
going to be so G Elliott Morris who is a
data journalist at The Economist
he says the biggest problem Republicans
face in the 2018 midterms is dummy man
during GOP mapmakers have spread their
voters too thin in districts that swing
around the D + 10 mark causing higher
seat loss and ten times the number of
competitive seats as Democrats so in
other words Republicans were trying to
gerrymander so that there was you know 2
percent more Republicans than Democrats
in a particular district but in off your
election those people don't show up and
so they actually created fewer hard red
districts and hard blue districts then
created a lot of purple districts in the
hopes that they would win that means a
lot of seats are vulnerable that means
there are a lot of seats that are
vulnerable so if you look at the AR plus
district if you look at the the vote of
the the Republican voters shared
districts there are at last count
between let's say the AR plus so first
of all I'm just counting the numbers
here 1 2 3 4 5 16 17 18 19 20 for one
there are 22 seats there are 22 seats in
which Democrats hold a majority of the
vote and in which Republicans hold seats
Republicans have 23 seat majority now
okay so that means there one seat away
from taking it here's the problem there
are also another there are also another
hundreds legitimately there know several
dozen seats there are several dozen
seats that are are plus ten or less
there another dozen dozens of seats I
mean I'm just looking at in the in the
AR plus one category okay in the AR plus
one category I mean in districts by the
way that are dead even there another two
districts there so that's 24 seats that
are either dead even or democratic plus
in a midterm election if you add in
areas where it's slightly R plus there
are another there another 10 seats that
are R plus 3 or so within our plus 3
okay so that means if Democrats have a
wave they could easily take 50 seats in
this election cycle if there's a wave
Democrats could easily take 50 seats in
the house okay this is dangerous
dangerous stuff and it is not good news
so this is why it is imperative the
president govern well it's why it's
imperative the president be popular and
why it's why it's imperative that the
President of the United States not do
stupid things and sink the instinct the
the the trade policy of the United
States okay meanwhile in in other news
that that is worth discussing Twitter
so Facebook has been just destroying
everybody who is in the news business
just destroying it there was a big
company yesterday that went under
because Facebook cut their revenues
seventy five percent it's not just
Facebook that's messing around with the
algorithms in order to hurt news
companies it is also Twitter that's
about to do so so Jack who was the head
of Twitter he he's tweeted out today
that he wants to commit Twitter to help
increase the collective health openness
and civility of public conversation and
hold ourselves publicly accountable
toward progress that means shutting down
more accounts presumably it means
banning more language it means that
Twitter is is sick of the blowback it's
getting from the left and they're gonna
start banning right-wing accounts and
you can see that this is happening on a
broader level there's a case that was
brought before the Supreme Court about
whether you could wear certain types of
t-shirts into polling places and this
case was pretty amazing the state of
Minnesota was trying to ban people from
wearing shirts that said the text of the
second amendment to the polls they're
saying oh that's that's electioneering
okay so these so Justice Alito asked
multi he went through a bunch of
different he went through a bunch of
different permutations of this could
wear this shirt could wear that shirt so
he said could you wear shirt that said I
love abortion and the people in
Minnesota the Minnesota lawyer said sure
that's no problem
so what could you wear a shirt that said
I love guns and they said no you can't
wear that shirt okay so in other words
there are lawyers in all of these states
who are now attempting to ban free
speech from people on the right it's not
a shock it is not a coincidence this is
a severe movement on the part of the
left in order to prevent anybody from
having an open and honest conversation
listen is there nastiness that happens
on Twitter yes I was the number one
recipient of it in 2016 is there
nastiness that happens in public
discourse I'm the guy who gets banned
from campuses yes there is I try to be
civil I like being simple I think it's
worthwhile to be civil but I don't want
an enforcement body sitting above anyone
either on Twitter or Facebook or in the
government saying that we are going to
pass rules about civility and then ban
people for it I would much rather have a
raucous nasty exchange of opinions and
have no exchange of opinions at all or
an approved exchange of opinions by our
masters and that's really gross okay so
in just a second we're gonna do some
things I like and some things I hate and
then we'll get to be fabled mailbag so
let's jump in with some things that I
like so the new Star Wars movies have
left me cold as you may have noticed so
I thought that the force awakens was
wildly overrated I also thought
that the that the sequel the last Jedi
was was over it was better than the
force awakens I'm the only person who
believes this apparently and I think
that the last Jedi was significantly
superior to the force awakens which I
thought was derivative and destroyed my
childhood by turning Han Solo into a
loser single dad who gets murdered by
his son so that that yuck okay but if
you actually want to read Star Wars
related stuff that's good okay Timothy
Zahn is a very very good science fiction
writer and I remember reading these when
I was a kid and he wrote a three-part
series that starts picks up right after
the destruction of the second Death Star
and it starts with the book heir to the
Empire and it tells a whole different
story than what's told in the force
awakens and it's way better they should
have just adapted these honestly they
should have just gone back and adapted
these because it's the books are much
much better it's about the rise of a
particular Admiral who's a brilliant
Admiral it's sort of on the outskirts of
the galaxy and how he manipulates things
that the Empire actually has a comeback
it's not just fast forward 40 years in
the first order is back and we don't
know how they got here why they're here
the book is well-written it's clever and
also the all of your favorite characters
actually appear so we don't have to deal
with all of the new characters that
nobody cares about and is hoping die as
soon as humanly possible right and it
doesn't cannibalize the the characters
that you love in order to preserve
characters who don't give a damn about
so check that out heir to the Empire by
Timothy Zahn okay other things that I
like so good for condi rice condi came
out and she said that we need gun rights
because they're victimized people who
still require guns she said guns help my
father protect our family during
segregation she said this on the view I
was little girl growing up in Birmingham
Alabama in the late fifties early
sixties there was no way that Bull
Connor and the Birmingham police were
going to protect you
and so when white knight writers would
come through our neighborhood my father
and his friends would take their guns
and they'd go to the head of the
neighbors a little cul-de-sac and they
would fire in the air if anybody came
through I don't think they actually ever
hit anybody but they protected the
neighborhood I'm sure if Bull Connor had
known where those guns were he wouldn't
have rounded them up and so I don't
favor some things like gun registration
okay good for condi this is exactly
right I wish condi were were the
spokesperson for the Republican Party
not Trump on guns I mean she's doing a
much better job
there
okay now time for a couple of things
that I hate and then we'll get to the
mailbag okay things I hate this entire
week other than that things that at
least done policy things that I hate so
the Oscars are coming up on Sunday so
we're all gonna sit around and pretend
to watch a three-hour show full of
obnoxious people who made movies no one
saw this year no one saw any of these
movies there were like two of these
movies that anybody saw one was get out
and the other was Dunkirk no one has
ever seen any of these other movies okay
the one that's going to win is so here's
a here's I'm gonna do I'm gonna describe
who I think are who I think gonna win
but I'm gonna do it in terms that you're
gonna understand because I'm gonna use
projects that you've actually seen
okay so here's who's gonna win
everything okay first of all the movie
that's going to win is grinding Nemo
okay that's the shape of water about a
woman who has sex with a fish
basically it's it's overrated left to
splash so check out gross so that's
that's it's gonna win grinding Nemo okay
the best director is the guy from
Hellboy the better that's guillermo del
toro the best actor is Commissioner
Gordon the best actress is the lady from
Fargo the best supporting actor is that
weird guy from Iron Man 2 and the best
supporting actress is the lady from
Roseanne there now you know you haven't
seen any of these movies but that's how
you're gonna know who these people are
you know there was a long period in in
America where the we're at the Oscars
every picture that one had had been a
box-office top top 20 film that's
because it used to be that the critics
respected the American public enough
that the American public actually liked
to go watch something they gave it a
little bit respect to the box office but
it just shows you anything that the
American people actually like to watch
the critics are going to denigrate as
crap for the masses unless of course it
fulfills certain intersectional check
boxes that means that we can already
write in Black Panther for Best Picture
next year I'm really looking forward to
that in fact they should give it all the
Oscars I think I think that first of all
I actually do think the Michael B Jordan
should probably be nominated for Best
Supporting Actor for for kill monger
because he's actually pretty great in
the film them but I think we should just
write it in for a suite because it's
very important honestly the only big
shock this year is that Wonder Woman
didn't win everything cuz it was the
greatest movie ever made according to
the critics because women okay so time
you know what I have to show you Alex
Jones just because Alex Jones man so
Alex Jones yesterday he
fighting back against accusations of
anti-semitism the way he fought back was
not the strongest way in the world
here's Alex Jones fresh off his
supplements talking about why he's not
anti-semitic and oh my god Wow my new
wife's purr pedigrees German 3/4 German
from Omaha and a quarter Irish and I'm
proud of that background and the NE
Semites call her a call her Jewish and
everything else and I am she was I'd be
proud of it but no she's got a noble
nose but she's not Jewish so you know
that's what all this comes down to
ladies and gentlemen so I'm not
admitting but my wife has a giant nose
and people think she's a Jew yeah
strong defense there Alex it's I got
handed to me Power Move Power Move Alex
Jones right there my wife's not a Jew
but she has big nose some people think
she's you but I'm not interested all
right time for the mailbag let's just do
it there are no more orders to be said
Thomas writes hi mr. Shapiro my name is
Thomas I'm a really big fan of the show
I'm a freshman at the University of
Southern Mississippi and I just got out
of high school I firmly believe the
reason for school shootings is social
outcasting the issue is not about easy
access to guns like the left believes
but an issue of values within those
students teenagers today are not being
talked at value such as humility and the
ability and self-discipline from their
parents
how should public schools go about
teaching good values and prevent kids
from becoming antisocial outcasts so I
think it's very difficult for public
schools to actually do that I think that
there can be lessons in virtue I think
personal responsibility starts at home
kids who are who lacked that are gonna
have trouble learning it at school I
don't think schools can necessarily fill
that gap but that but a school that that
treats everybody as as a victim is not
going to is not going to succeed either
so I think schools used to generate a
better feeling of community when
communities were stronger themselves I
again I'm not gonna put it on the
schools to teach virtue to kids I just
don't think that's how it works I think
that the vast majority of children is
how virtue by their parents this is a
parental problem there's a reason a
disproportionate number these school
shooters don't have a biological father
living in the home now Elizabeth says -
love your show what is a good book to
read about the history of the Second
Amendment Thank You Liz so there are a
couple of good books
I believe Gordon wood talks about the
history of the Second Amendment and some
his books on the foundation of the
Constitution there's I believe Paul
Johnson may talk about a little bit in
history of the American people there's
also a bunch of actually his name
escapes me right now it's right on the
tip of my tongue there's a professor at
Yale who's actually on the left who does
an excellent analysis of sort of
originalist doctrine on the Second
Amendment and when I remember his name I
will bring it up but it's a lot of
common law stuff so there's some good
common law books on it justice Bork has
a couple of books in which he discusses
the Second Amendment Dean says hi Ben my
name is Dean I'm a seventeen year old
junior in high school and I'm a firm
believer in the Second Amendment a
member of the NRA at the moment myself
and others in my school are being
threatened by the leftist narrative the
we are heartless coward for defending
our rights my school will allow students
to do a walkout I and others will not
participate because it is obviously all
about gun control Ben how should my
friends and I exhibit our First
Amendment during the walkout it's
obvious that myself another conservative
high schoolers are being threatened do
you have any advice for us thanks for
all you do god bless Shapiro's 2020 okay
so here is my advice I think that you
should walk out with all the other kids
and I think you should bring a sign that
says here to save lives
I love the Second Amendment okay I think
you should say I think that you should
you should say both of those things I
think that you should make it clear that
you are there to help save lives and
prevent school shootings and that these
two things are connected the reason that
you like the Second Amendment is so good
people can stop bad people Kyle says hey
Ben what do you think the next
large-scale global catastrophe will be
examples such as World War three u.s.
Civil War global economic collapse
global pandemic and so on well it's hard
to predict a pandemic I would say that
you know the chances of a pandemic have
grown because of the resistance of two
new antibiotics of some strains of
disease so that's always a solid bet
because pandemics do happen as far as
global economic collapse I don't think
that's gonna happen anytime in the near
future unless we actually start if by
global economic collapse we mean a
severe economic recession or depression
I think that you could see that but I
don't think it's gonna last you know
inevitably or interminably World War
three I think the possibility exists but
it's it's not super high I actually
don't think that we are on the verge of
a global catastrophe I think the
greatest catastrophe that could happen
right now is America
falling more and more into the trap
of european-style thinking because we
have abandoned American founding
principle and a slow slide I would say
into global degrade degredation
on the economic and moral scale I think
that's probably the worst thing that
could happen I don't think it's gonna be
like a big flashpoint World War three
everybody's too afraid to nukes at this
point for that to really happen
the Andersons recently I've been reading
about dialectical materialism is
flossing pretty evident it's wise
Marxist thought so attracted to
intellectuals well the reason it's so
attractive to intellectuals is because
intellectuals like to think that they
are smarter than the common man and that
the reason that the society has not
worked is because they're not in charge
commands and control economies are very
attractive to people who think they are
much smarter than everybody else
capitalism free market economics lays a
fair these assume that Joe Schmo Plummer
knows better to do with his money then
you know what to do with his money and
intellectuals don't like that very much
intellectuals like to think that they
know better what to do with your money
then you know what to do with your money
they think that everybody is ruled by
passion except for them they're the
reasonable people at the top who can
construct society in such a way so that
everyone is happy and hence the the
drive toward that hence the drive toward
progressivism
and bureaucracy and the notion of
expertise ruling the roost the thing is
that collective expertise is always
better than individual expertise this is
why command and control economies always
fail because when you have somebody at
the top who supposedly knows about trade
that person knows way less about trade
than the collective intelligence of the
American people for example who trade
with each other on a daily basis Spencer
says what do you think it would take to
revive the shared sense of purpose they
characterize American society up until
the late 20th century so I am writing a
book on this right now I'm about halfway
through that book I think it's going to
require a renewed teaching of values
that spring from judeo-christian culture
as well as Greek reason so the Greek
style enlightenment the the Lockean
philosophy that they combined these two
forces we're gonna have to relocate a
sense of community based on a value
system that is judeo-christian and
origin and also based on a Greek
teleology that suggests that you can
discover morality by using logic and
reason and the nature of the universe
around you you can't just come up with
moral systems in your head that have no
relation to the nature of things in the
nature of being but you can by
investigating the nature of the universe
see what they what the underlying cause
of things is and therefore come up with
with certain aspects of virtue in order
to boil that down into practical
practice you usually need some form of
religion judeo-christian religion
most prominent Matthew says dear Ben
with YouTube being as large as it is
today do you think there's an issue with
the way they're handling their business
should we just attempt to take our
business elsewhere if we do not agree
with their practice or is it possible
that outlets like YouTube and Twitter
need to potentially have regulations so
this is a serious question I know the
Prager you has been suing YouTube over
exactly this issue so their private
business I think they should do what
they want but they are violating their
own Terms of Service and they're lying
about it this is my problem with Twitter
YouTube and Facebook it's not that
they're private businesses and they say
listen we're gonna crack down on
conservative websites you do that fine
we all go form our own business the
problem is they're lying they're saying
we're free speech outlets
we're not penalizing specific people
we're not setting up our algorithms to
penalize say Daily wire content while
boosting TYT content and then that's
exactly what they do they set up their
algorithms that way when you lie now
you're talking about defrauding people
and there you may have a legal case so I
think that's the bit like Facebook right
now is screwing people so hard who spent
a lot of money on algorithm on trying to
figure out their algorithms building a
Facebook following and then Facebook
basically decided they wanted to
downgrade certain kinds of content in
order to upgrade kinds of content they
find more genteel and amiable and that's
I think defrauding clients I think it's
just defraud in customers now Phil says
hi Ben have you talked previously on
homelessness how most people do not have
a right to the streets and that they
should seek community support my
question is what do you think we should
do specifically there's a large homeless
population many of whom don't have a
community to fall back on I agree that
people should set themselves up in a
community that's not the reality in many
cases what should be done now to fix the
problem well the answer is that if
you're living on the street should be
arrested okay really if you are living
on the street you should be arrested and
then you are one of a few types of
people either you are mentally ill
you're one of the mentally ill who's on
the street in which case we should be
looking at the commitment and we should
be looking at mental health treatment
for you and if it has to be involuntary
because otherwise you're a schizophrenic
and you're out wandering the streets is
a danger to yourself then that's the way
it's got to be if you're a drug user
then drug use is still a crime in the
United States oh or at least living on
the street is so if you're living on the
street we'll either arrest you or we
will or you know if you're using it will
try to detox you we'll do our best to
help you put you in a community center
but if you're back on the street again
we'll arrest you again very little of
this is economically driven isn't the
point that I'm making here because we
were just a matter of economics
therefore there are a lot of homeless
people then the answer would presumably
be that there's not much you can do
unless you generate more jobs but that's
really not the biggest problem with
homelessness okay let's see Zachary's
has been a couple of weeks ago on your
mailbag you said the Federal Reserve was
into necessary components of the central
bank well I agree that the Fed is mostly
dead wait what are the consequences of
allowing the inflation rate to rise or
fall out of the constraints set by the
Fed who would adjust interest rates
thanks Zack well I'm in favor of going
back to a gold system I know that this
is considered heresy now or at least I'm
in favor of pegging the price of the
dollar to to the price of gold so the
gold system suggested you can actually
physically turn in your dollar for a
certain amount of go but I don't know
that you actually have to do that well
you could do instead is simply pegged
the price of the dollar to the price of
gold which was the Bretton Woods system
up until it was revoked in the 1970s so
I don't see the reason we couldn't go
back to something like that and it would
be automatic Tyler's has been can you
give your opinion on capital punishment
and how to argue for it but still hold
the belief that killing is sin so the
answer is well on the biblical level
there's the word that is used in the
Bible is do not murder okay there's a
different word in Hebrew for murder than
for killing the word in Hebrew is low
tare Tov right low means no fair Tov
means you shouldn't murder okay so there
you should not murder is that is that
rule okay it is not lo taha rogue
taharoa would be don't kill so on a
biblical level nowhere in the bible does
it says say that you shouldn't have
death penalty in fact the death penalty
is prescribed for a wide variety of
crimes in the bible itself okay on just
a secular moral level there are certain
crimes that are so egregious that if you
were to keep people in jail for them you
would be doing a disservice to the
society at large so I'm not even talking
about it on a deterrent level there are
two types of things are trying to deter
one is you're trying to deter people
from committing the crimes they know
that the death penalty and the second
thing is you're trying to deter tribal
vengeance and one of the reasons that
the government has a monopoly on the
legal use of force except in
self-defense is because what we don't
want is tribal warfare tribal warfare
usually happens when you have one tribe
and they kill somebody from the other
tribe and then the second tribe says you
know in revenge we're gonna go kill
somebody from the first tribe and then
the first tribe says oh my god you
killed that guy let's go kill that guy
from the second tribe this is how Wars
start is how intertribal conflicts start
it's why gang violence which is
basically just tribal conflicts in the
inner cities is so is so awful that's
why you actually need a system where
people feel like the problem is being
taken care of by a third power
and that problem does involve the
execution of people who kill other
people Jessie says hi been huge fan we
were having election for our City
Council and mayor this year in campaign
finance reform is a huge topic as I'm
doing the research for myself I'm
curious as to what your opinion is on
campaign finance regulation on a federal
state and local level I do not think
that the government ought to ought to be
involved in campaign finance regulation
on any level I think they should be
involved in bribery and if you are
bribing somebody to vote a certain way
that is a crime but if I decide to spend
my money and my friends and I decide to
spend my money on an election I don't
see the problem with that and I think
it's an aspect of free speech yeah it's
my money I should be able to do with it
what I want I should be able to say what
I want I should be able to buy the free
speech that I'm capable of having it
isn't under the government's business
because once the government butts in
it's pretty rare that it's not going to
have some sort of impact that it's
politically motivated campaign finance
reform is being pushed by Democrats not
because Democrats actually care about
corruption in the in the election system
because they're perfectly happy with
watching unions spend millions of
dollars billions of dollars actually on
politicians they like it's because they
think they're gonna be ruling out the
rich fat cats on Wall Street but while
allowing the unions to do what they want
House has been Jordan Peterson argues IQ
of the poppy 15 percent of the
population has an IQ so low they can't
function in a normal job how would you
as a libertarian support these people so
I'm sure this is true I mean there are
percentages of the population that can't
have a normal job I know it's 15 percent
but there's certainly a certain percent
and the answer is that community is
supposed to pick up the slack and that
you're supposed to actually have local
viable communities which is why you do
need religious communities it's why you
need to have local communities where
people get together know each other and
like each other and it becomes a common
commitment to help people who can't take
care of themselves otherwise it's gonna
get thrown on government kate says hey
Ben if you were a cheese which cheese
would you be I don't know that's it
that's not a good question I don't know
the answer to that because I don't know
cheese as well enough to have a solid
answer to that the off the top of my
head
mozzarella may be mild but completes
every dish that's not right now
boo-ki sorry getting booed in the studio
by my own people yeah I don't know I
pass would you say sharp cheddar okay
maybe that's fair
hey Ben I want to tell you that I love
your show and no BS approach to politics
and the many topics that come with it I
questioned you today is what brought you
to be up a die-hard White Sox fan I'm a
die-hard Cubs fan have been born and
raised in Chicago Northwest Indiana area
the rivalry between the two teams is
great so why the Sox because my dad is a
Sox fan you grew up a Sox fan we wrote
an entire book called say it so about
the 2005 White Sox championship season
you can get that over at Amazon the so
we are huge Sox fans because and I will
pass it down to my son because suffering
is just in our nature I need to pass
down to my son rooting for a team that
nobody else roots for and that has only
won one World Series in the past hundred
years let's see one more question
Chelsea says hey Ben what is it that
makes children thrive more academically
socially and emotionally with married
parents than with cohabiting parents who
do not separate what it is exactly that
makes marriage so beneficial Thanks well
number one Co happening parents who do
not separate there's still the
possibility there do a separate there's
a burden to overcome when people get
married what you're really doing is you
are setting up an obstacle to you
getting out right you're locking the
door behind you when you're just
cohabiting there's always the feeling
that one person has at least one foot on
the threshold because there's no loss of
income there's no community property
there's no there's no notion that you
actually lose anything by walking out
the door so every day is a real value a
ssin as to whether this ought to happen
once you've pre committed it's it's sort
of like a game of chicken when you put a
brick on the accelerator and you show
everybody the done so once you've done
that you've pre committed to everybody
else that you are not walking out that
door and children need to feel that
sense of community I think it's very
important the children feel secure and
their upbringing secure that mommy and
daddy are still going to be there to
help them and cohabitation by the way is
a really bad indicator cohabitation
before marriage it is inversely
proportional to lasting marriages after
marriage so if you go happen for a long
time then you get married the chances
that you stay married as a statistic are
much lower than if you were just to get
married without KY happening first okay
so we'll be back here next week we can
all hope and pray the policy gets better
in the meantime because the last 48
hours have been garbaggio
so mr. president do better and I'll be
happy to talk about that I hope you do
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alec singhara audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Joshua Oliveira the Ben Shapiro show is
a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright for publishing 2018